I mean new Trek has always been a bit
divisive but this musical
welcome to say Trek your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so at San Diego Comic Con at the weekend
they announced that yes we are getting a
Star Trek musical strange new worlds
Subspace Rhapsody
there are going to be 10 original songs
and a version of Bohemian Rhapsody in
that episode and lots of people are
seriously excited about this and I have
no complaints with any of you if you're
looking forward to this brilliant
and lots of people have also gone nuts
now I'm in between my personal opinion
here is that I'm a little disappointed
I'm not particularly looking forward to
it I don't like musicals you know I
don't watch any I'm I'm not watching
Sound of Music at Christmas I've watched
Chitty Chitty Bang Bang when I was a kid
um I think I watched the Moulin Rouge
that's about it I'm not excited but
because it's a musical not because it's
Star Trek musical but other people are
quite angry
why
if you're a Trekkie for one you love
Star Trek so when Star Trek does
something you don't like you're going to
have an emotional reaction you're going
to get upset and that's okay it's
because we love it that we get upset if
we didn't like Star Trek we wouldn't
care so first of all if somebody you
know or somebody's on a group on
Facebook or whatever and they're not
happy about this it's because they love
the show and they're just expressing
their disappointment it's okay
but I do think there are actually some
real reasons why some people are not
happy about this
for one we only get 10 episodes of
strange new worlds thanks to strike we
don't know when or even if we're getting
strange new worlds again this could be
the final season with the strikes and
everything else nothing is guaranteed
now I think we will be getting another
season of strange new world I'm pretty
like 95 certainly well but it's possible
but even if it does come back for third
season we've no idea when will it be
next year probably not so we're going to
be waiting a little while for any more
strange new worlds we've only got three
episodes left at the point of recording
and out of the seven episodes that we've
had we've already kind of had two comedy
episodes already you know where spot got
turned into a human that was you know
maybe an exploration into the character
spot but it was mostly you know a funny
episode and a very good episode
we've also had the you know um lower
decks crossover episode
perfect Star Trek I adore that episode
I've watched it twice I might watch it a
third time it's one of my favorite Star
Trek episodes pretty much ever
um well it was still a very risky
episode and even though it was
traditional science fiction in lots of
ways it was still you know
a comedy episode there was a lot of
humor in there it was very quirky so
we've had two quirky risky sort of funny
episodes already the first episode also
wasn't very good the second episode was
okay but you know for me I was just
irritated by The Logical errors so some
people are upset because
Star Trek real estate Star Trek time is
valuable and we're losing three of them
to Comedy quirky silly episodes for
actual science fiction fans you're going
to be watching us going well where's the
drama where's the action where's the
Star Trek because you know Star Trek
might have like moments but it's not all
and out comedy TNG never had episodes
like this Voyager didn't avoid you maybe
Deep Space Nine have one or two that
were a little bit like this but not
really all out
so where's the Star Trek
that's why some people are quite angry
about this because again this musical
I'm sorry I don't care what reason they
give for everybody suddenly dancing in
perfect choreography and everybody
knowing the same song all at once
there's not going to be scientific
genuine reason for that it's it's going
to be some sort of weird it looks like
some sort of weird energy wave or
something that hits everybody and okay
maybe they're gonna say it's mind
control or something but yeah they're
gonna be having to push the reason out
there it's going to be random so I have
to say this is not going to be a science
fiction episode but is there a way they
could have done this episode and
actually not wound everybody up yeah do
a surprise 11th episode that's the way
to do it to excite people even I not
loving musicals would have been like
yeah bonus episode there's going to be a
musical I'll watch that but as it's not
a bonus episode as it's the ninth
episode of the Season what we would
normally hope would be you know sort of
like the first of a two-parter something
really action-packed something really
that affects the start to track universe
as a whole
instead is going to be this musical so
we're going to have the final episode
I'm hoping the gone thing that has been
suggested and hinted at a few times
already then the series is going to be
explained there
but they've only got one episode to do
it
I just wished we'd have maybe had a bit
more of an impressive finale now maybe
they're gonna surprise us again and
maybe episode 10 will actually be a two
apple to our episode maybe it'll be a
two-parter in one sort of thing
they haven't announced it if they're
going to
but either way I just feel personally
like we've been robbed a little bit and
I think other people are actually quite
angry that we've been robbed
and by that I mean we've lost a genuine
hour of Star Trek
to a musical
and if you don't like musicals
that really does feel like
betrayal
now the other thing is new Trek is quite
divisive anyway people do either quite
like it love it even or really really
have a problem with it now even trekkies
they will watch it but they come away
almost every episode just thinking oh
god I've done it to me again a lot of
trekkies have turned away from Star Trek
and that really is a crime
Alex kurtzman and everybody else have
done some brilliant Star Trek don't get
me wrong but they've also done some
pretty bad mistakes you know even I
turned my back on Discovery and I do
consider myself a pretty loyal Trekkie
I will talk to you guys about when they
do things I don't like I will talk to
you guys about how frustrated I get by
some of the mistakes because some of the
mistakes is so mad at me
but I still go back I'm still hopeful
that the next episode is going to be
something I can really adore I will
always be a Trekkie in my heart
the fact that Alex kurtzman has actually
turned people like me away from Star
Trek forever is sad
and I just think that more episodes like
this are just going to turn even more
people off and that's really sad
so yeah I wish they hadn't have done the
musical in this episode I just think
that the crossover episode and this
musical in one season is too much if
they'd have done this musical as a
Christmas special or something I don't
know you know a one-off thing separate
people would have gone crazy I think or
if they'd have done it in next season
you know and they would have done it you
know that one quirky weird episode per
season is no problem at all we can enjoy
it then we don't feel like we're having
something taken away from us
that's why I think so many people are
quite angry about the Star Trek Musical
now I thought and this is a positive
Point here I thought the lower decks
crossover was just stupid I thought it
was a ridiculous idea and let's be
honest it was
but they did it so well so beautifully
that it actually is genuinely one of the
best episodes of Star Trek I've ever
seen definitely of new track 100 of news
records it's up there top five new track
Star Trek episodes easy
they executed it perfectly and that is
the point if the musical is done well it
will still be enjoyable but I will
always have the back of my mind that
this could have and maybe should have
been a more traditional Star Trek style
sci-fi episode but hey let's have an
open mind let's remember that actually
they have done some really brilliant
episodes of strange new worlds and
actually you know let's give them the
benefit of the doubt that this might
just actually make sense when we watch
it I keep saying on this channel and
let's not batter things down that we
haven't seen yet let's give it an
opportunity I can honestly say I'm not
looking forward to it but that's because
I don't like musicals not because I
think this is some sort of just terrible
idea to begin with I'm willing to give
the creators a chance
I hope you do too but guys get into the
comments and tell me what you really
think because this is divisive
is there a reason why you don't like
this idea that I've not mentioned is
there something I've not thought about
or you know do you actually just think
no I just don't like it because it's a
musical it's as simple as that or is
this just one more example of new track
and Alex kurtzman's track just
messing around with Star Trek and using
it like a toy instead of actually the
amazing sci-fi franchise that it is
I wish they'd take it maybe a little bit
more seriously
Discovery they took way too seriously
strange new worlds I've gone away the
other way but what do you think is more
important get into the comments if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you can follow
all these links that have been wandering
around across the bottom and as always
guys please live long and prosper and
I'll see you next time
good
foreign